he's down there now so he's not so loud
i'm so sorry he is loud he is so loud i
i he was bleeding over into my interview
oh my god no no what are we well it's
okay it's just he goes hunting a lot so
that boom has messed up his ears
completely i said he can't hear me how
is he judging my brother can't he can't
listen
some kind of way he's doing it i don't
know lord have mercy lord have mercy
okay well living legend young legend at
that thank you very much hall of famer
i'll take that as a compliment
considering
considering they call me papa lionel one
more time i'm going to scream but i'll
take it there
no no but you know we are not a papaline
but i must tell you though it
it's endearing when you have the kids
nine eight
seven years old going high lionel hi pop
call me anything at that age they don't
even recognize you if you're an adult
but in the in the hall of fame situation
you know when you finally make it yeah
it's it's really quite satisfying
because we all put the work in i mean
artists you have to understand this is
this is a struggle to get here and then
besides getting in how about living to
get in
because it's a tough business it's a
really tough business but
i am so happy yeah you are so incredibly
iconic okay
is there anything left on your bucket
list like what haven't you done that you
want to do as an artist i'm looking
forward to tomorrow you know in other
words you know every day you create the
next adventure right so if you're
resting on hey let me tell you what i
did yesterday then you miss the future
so as long as i show up for the future
i'm the happiest guy in the world i love
that is there anybody you want to work
with that you haven't had a chance to
work with
yeah oh my god
it's sharing i would like to be uh right
on the i mean
we've crossed paths with everybody right
now is working you know bruno i mean i
can tell you the guys these are
songwriters yes so again that's the fun
of it all right um but you know we'll
we'll get there give me about 80 more
years and i'll
i'll figure it out
are you making bets on who you think's
going to win do you have a hunch on who
you think's going to win no no because i
tried that the first two seasons
and
and my bet i lost so much money it was
unbelievable because well remember that
i can't i don't know you can't even talk
about betting on this show so i can't
say it but i lost a lot of money
but the point here is
that
the kids are now being judged by the
voters by the public yes and so when you
have that kind of scrutiny going i don't
want to know where they're going because
the person
for example sam
a couple of years ago if you told me sam
was going to win i said
sam took the prize and went home i mean
so i at this point i stopped betting on
that
okay
saving money
good to see you
such a pleasure
thank you very much